greetings from podcast Ville its October
first the renter's do [ __ ] up is but
the church what's happening now is
brought to you by my bookie listen my
book is slammed with new betters and
wants to give everyone the best possible
service if you're willing to deposit
after 7:00 p.m. Eastern they'll give you
an additional $25 free play on deposits
over a hundred like Joey why should I go
with my bookie why cuz you're a [ __ ]
cuz you need you would you win you get
paid that's why that's what that's the
[ __ ] basic truth right there if you're
gonna take in a baton tonight if you're
thinking of putting in a bet you gotta
check out my bookie alright go to my
bookie dot-com right now and at the
promo code Church to activate the offer
visit my bookie online today that's my
bookie my Bo ok ie and don't forget to
use promo code church and the church
what's happening I was brought to you by
on it
listen I just got back from [ __ ] boss
and you know I'm tip-top Magoo on it the
[ __ ] in the immune tech and my alpha
brain and the [ __ ] protein shake
that's why before I fly you got on a
plane you see these Japanese people with
masks [ __ ] that [ __ ] I popped three of
those shroom tech immunes and listen I
come out of their [ __ ] singing opera
understand me so gonna calm right now
press in church BAM and get 10% off kick
this [ __ ] mule leaf finally finally
hmm I get to get my little brother in
here 20 years of the show mr. Aron Kader
man create a [ __ ] blossom axis of
evil tour the whole [ __ ] deal talk to
me
bless you some of my earliest memories
of comedy or through you you know DC or
y'all got it out here with us no I came
out here in 93 went to LA City College
and an older brother who was a USC
percussionist musician and so I was
friends with all those guys but uh just
would go to LA City College and I took
acting class and then somebody came in
from The Groundlings did a class and I
saw improv and [ __ ] you know it blows
your mind and when you first see it you
know it's magical
and I and then I took acting class then
I went to Groundlings and then I was
waiting to go through the levels and
then I start to stand out and what was
the first place that you watch stay in
the bed
it was the belly room what made you walk
into the comedy shows a thousand little
places - I know it was Barnhart
I'm suddenly like mm-hmm and Kirsten and
Lynn Cynthia l'viv uh-huh
and you know Adam Baltar is still there
on Sunday nights rehab speed craziness
he is one of the best guy yeah in Kabul
yeah I was friends with him him and I
would sit and talk about addiction like
he was bummed um I was [ __ ] up it was
all a little secret
we shared drugs from time to time you
know I know he was gay as [ __ ]
which made me love me this show was
crazy yes there's one Sunday nights like
I would get there earlier before hosting
and dubash cuz he also talked like a
comedy class yeah I start teaching
teaching oh yeah so I did some speaking
for him but then he went away for a
while yeah and we kept in touch of on
the phone it's so weird all the
personalities yeah and I see him up
there now but he was like a rock rock
like rock star gay rock star kind of
person yes yes days yeah you know he was
eccentric to these LA yeah I never seen
anything like Adam like he does some
crazy thing that you know it's just
always on the line of figuring out what
is is what is it when Mitch he would
make somebody a regular and they were
gay they were [ __ ] good at gay copies
whenever the [ __ ] came out of that mouth
was cold like and then last for a long
time because I said member Nate I was
talking to some what was the place off
Melrose no it was off Santa Monica it
was Reinhard a [ __ ] Boys Town it was
down one of those streets and it was in
a basement and I'm like Tuesday nights
it wasn't Wargo
it had a different name don't know if
you were around for that
not on promenade not out in demonic no
Loulou this is in Santa Monica West
Holly right then let's Cienega you
hooker right
oh god Santa Monica if you would a mile
you went too fast
uh-huh it was behind it was our sultry
going down towards Melrose and there was
a place in there I still seen dice there
upstairs and place was so hot like it
was before Jay Davis and yeah thousand
right I met I met first got the bar next
to Jay Davis that was the first place I
met a man I met in 98 I was a Comedy
Store regular with on Tuesday nights he
booked a place called the Union the
Union and it was right about the time
when that movie came out here with his
two roommates Oh the play swingers
swingers swingers so Vince Vaughn dated
a girl and all of them lived together
but then the girl in Vince Vaughn broke
up and she started booking calmly huh
so she would book that room on Tuesdays
and it became like one of the biggest
rooms on the strip on Tuesday because
Tuesdays was yeah why so Tori's night at
the college that Tuesday was saying
white people would get intimidated and
they would go to you know Comedy Store
yeah so you smile at the Comedy Store
and Tuesday was always a [ __ ] spot yeah
it was always eight people OS I think it
took the floor to start the show but he
had eight people like it was so
intimidating when you went past account
it's nothing about prejudice or anything
like that it was just that there was 600
black people in a [ __ ] area of Sunset
that would you scare the [ __ ] out of
white people it was well no it was Lee I
mean everybody black celebrities were
there like celebrities I'm talking about
it was real ah it was a hot spot
Limbaugh was pulling up and it was just
a hot spot so why people said we don't
belong there
so unless you stay that there I saw def
Comedy Jam yeah unless you stayed at the
hotel next door or across the street and
stumbled into a Comedy Store you weren't
and that was known in LA so that every
Tuesday became an alternative
nights of wet yeah so Largo had comedy
with Sarah Silverman's
Mitch Hedberg you know all those guys
and then there was another club that the
guy who ran it God rest his soul he's
dead he was a guy from Long Island that
had a great bit about a B but if you
went downstairs that's where we talked
about last night after the podcast we
were talking about girls who suck dick
I'm gonna forget that I was there one
day like I was like this was the hot
spot at the time this is before I met I
bet this had to be 97 West Hollywood
this is when there was a bikini bar
that's still there I think in West
Hollywood it's a straight-up bikini bar
and they did comedy on Tuesdays so if
you were lucky you got a spot at the
bikini bar and then you went over to
that bar but that other bar the
downstairs was a showcase room hmm so
was filled with agents hmm so you had to
be a certain type of traveling or the
guy had to like if a guy had attitude
because he knew now that his room could
blow you up
but the first time I went to the bikini
room Walt Frazier was know oh it's the
guy that said he [ __ ] a thousand women
oh well we'll Chamberlain yeah wait damn
there goes my galley like well chamber
was things as they are the [ __ ] oh
we're all there doing comedy nobody paid
attention to comics I forget who booked
that room and then we go over to that
other place and watch the comics that
would go up and then we'll all the
hottest Montreal ComicCon man no Tommy
Largo huh no Lago was ball tournament
was on Fairfax yeah right Fairfax up to
court it was called somewhere the Largo
though yes brother Lee two places God
the water from Canter's ah that was like
the last beats a place it was open till
3:00 rogue will always take their cross
from Canter's yes yes that would sell me
on oh [ __ ] good yeah dad a good sandwich
but that too I know if the guy was
telling the story after the podcast that
was the first time ever
I had been the only 7 months I didn't
know the game oh you had just gotten to
LA and just away this is the hottest
club the hottest clubs were you know the
cloudy snow is just a [ __ ] splatoon
yeah in those days it was just known as
the coke place to dump yeah it was
colorful funny but you don't want to be
there he went dark yeah laughs factory
was the hip Club and The Improv had
always been hit because J and Nano and
all that will start so the Comedy Store
was the pits
yeah we're just happy to get spots there
right but you got to go around town and
do different routes mm-hmm but that was
the first time ever I'll never forget
this girl good-looking girl with the
[ __ ] leopard top uh came up to me
she's like what do you do with you
they're like oh I'm doing the spot and
she goes did they give you 10 or 15
minutes I think I told it they gave me
15 minutes and she said to me what if I
suck your dick for seven and a half of
those minutes and I don't forget what
you're looking at I go what did you just
say I can save me saying this to
somebody like you're saying you want
eight minutes yeah I could see me say
that but a woman saying it can ask are
you [ __ ] crazy and I just saw her
she's through the game really yes she's
still the game fat huge all really puffy
lips
you could plastic surgery trick are you
even allowed to do that like you go to
the manager be like hey I'm gonna give
Sally give us a minute my business will
be right back put somebody up before me
cuz you cannot get the minutes until you
suck my dick you know I'm saying I was
strict about their diet you don't get
the time this ain't on credit either
yeah thank you Bob but you're depressing
you suck my dick crying because you
ain't in front of Gersh that's not my
problem you gotta give it to me up front
that's even if you know I'm just saying
this is a joke people what would the
manager say if he told I don't know I
know it's like Mitzi says well you would
probably suck his dick no I wouldn't
even ask something like Mitzi I never
forget being at the Laugh Factory John
and I had 20 minutes in front of water
brothers with nine somebody came up to
me Paul Rodriguez and asked me to give
ten of my minutes to John Fox
I don't know what we're
would you remember the Dave Mitzi you
know made you a regular yeah a good
birthday what was that
baby baby seven yeah he bids you've been
out here for a few months I was out here
for a month and I turned into third week
she may be a regular that's how lucky I
was
then you went back got your [ __ ] my bad
life there was no gettin no [ __ ] your
[ __ ] I had a duffel bag of the dream hey
no book that was it no headshots
I still remember get into a store and
taking headshots that Monday the piano
play it yeah was a piano plan that like
my girlfriend so he's like I'll do the
headshots for free that headshot you see
me with sunglasses that's it at the
storm that was that nice that was my
first [ __ ] real headshot I had taken
that shot some Seattle baby but I didn't
figure with his head shots like I did he
said top picture look pictures dip but
da when you got here on that trip you
were coming from Colorado or that you
Seattle you were coming from Seattle yes
okay so you're bouncing around you end
up getting to LA why'd you move to LA
though ducks the hook told me that I had
the chance
oh so you don't comedy and see yeah I
was do going to see how you say the
first though I started Debra Debra what
age were you when you started 28 yeah I
was about that was like twenty six seven
and that's gonna sit it longer the tooth
28 I know when I got here people were
like he's too old
he's too old and I looked old I was 32
34 35 and the hottest manager at the
time when I got hit was bosina Baker mmm
and he was hanging out at the Comedy
Store one night and that same girl that
offered to suck my dick the seven
minutes was talking to him one day I'll
never forget this and he told her he
said to her from BB in the arms distance
I can hear distance whatever that
expression is from her he said you're
done in this tab Eliot 28000 getting
coked up listen to that conversation the
next day I went back to him I saw like I
can I talk to you about something yeah
not for nothing you got three of our
hottest clients of the business and
they're all tile over 28 you got Tim
Allen you got Drew Carey yeah and he had
somebody else at the time that was 41
song Oh what the [ __ ] are you talking
about
he thought about it for a few minutes
that he knows you baby right I don't
[ __ ] right why would you make that
statement yeah
and he was a cool guy like he was
understanding but you're never done here
it's true you never done look at [ __ ]
Vicki Baugh go back now I know look at
the he blahblah well it may be maybe
people have always been able to be
character actors and come from comedy
and become actors and being a bunch of
stuff but but this whole standard thing
changed when people start making
comebacks you know there used to be
people would make a mistake they were
gone kind of get buried and stuff you
couldn't have second third acts I think
all that's changed it's always changed
yeah they've all listen Marlon Brando
got a second chance yeah with more
Brando got the Godfather not want him on
the [ __ ] him didn't want him on the
[ __ ] lot paramount whoever did that
woman whatever studio didn't her mouth
was like we don't want him in this
[ __ ] movie he caused a disaster i
mutiny on the bounty cost everybody
millions of dollars Brando yeah we don't
want this guy in the lot you know after
[ __ ] Iron Man got caught with the
[ __ ] hula hoop and the costume doing
blow at some hotel room what's his name
Robert Downey jr. right who was gonna
give that poor kid a chance
yeah but tan the cream always rises to
the yeah yeah and people acknowledge the
second mistake and the most important
thing is when you do get that second
chance you gotta jump on it yeah you
have to [ __ ] go reborn throw punches
to me gays and bees you know it's not
that's the problem with this town
sometimes that people get a warm light
thrown on and then not really mentally
prepared they're not mentally prepared
you know I I'll even admit to that
myself because you know the things that
between 2000 and
two thousand four or six you know the
internet exploded and everybody had
their thing online you know and when
Dane Cook emelian my myspace people like
changed this whole game for a lot of
people and all the young comedians that
came up started to see the thing you
know happening with it and so then you
know we're taking a headshot trying to
make it tape you know video VHS tape to
send to an agent and and it's getting
everything's changing and it's getting
harder you have you gotta like shoot
something I produce it know how to
[ __ ] engineer it and get a computer
and you know edit it that was just like
all of a sudden that was our game it
wasn't just be funny you know I mean it
was like package that [ __ ] up and so it
was the art of it but be funny always
with that's what's trying to do is
really be funny always wins it's all
distractions that you take to be funny
to throw you off
mm-hmm being funny always with putting
the work in always with knowing that you
put the work in really win but before
because you know before the world of
email how would you build a following on
the road by being funny but being funny
but what was the other part of that that
was like the main guy's mouth that's it
word of mouth and what's happening how
are you doing good what's going on but
LA City College take your [ __ ]
classes but I got a part-time job at The
Whisky A Go Go bouncing no way my
favorite band from Boston is playing
whisky a go-go when they're [ __ ]
tremendous really what's their name
Aerosmith go watch them and that was it
when you bought when you produce an
album but they came out there was no
billboards it was a magazines and you
read about it in cream magazine and the
radio might play a new hit but a lot of
[ __ ] wasn't amp playable you know my big
10-inch you could plan on the rain you
know there was some Sabbath to getting
him
way there was all these different groups
but I've always believed in worried
about ok worried enough is the what guys
like a Mencia he had Flyers he would
take the names he would have listened
very Betsy it did something that I
always thought was pretty great and this
was at the end of the show he would his
brother would come with him so he
trusted his own flesh and what he would
say if you enjoyed the show tonight on
the way out give my brother $20 and
they'll bill you a copy of tonight's
seashell and they would go back to the
hotel room and print the show up all
night and if machs is prepared with that
date and the next morning before they
left town he would print them up mm-hmm
there were people that left cards on
tables it took emails of email blast to
Jimmie åkesson even before emailed
though he was doing that right
submitting you all then I what they got
a click on them and they get deleted
right off the bat
most of my mom says be sure every
morning I wake up and just that's what I
never believed that he built that's a
little bit too personal you know I've
called into a little bit person was more
mailing list there was more Bailey wish
like that seal it up a Flyers out yeah
you know will enter the showcase at the
store you had to go make a hundred
flyers and go to every casting office by
hand and go hi my name is Joey Diaz
we're doing a showcase they both smoke
up your ass will definitely a new
corridor is VP Lloyd and the name of the
show you'd have one call from like your
int you know it was embarrassing but
these are the things that you had to do
to learn whether or not they failed
look I stupid Josh will get this one-man
show and getting your deal from Fox
what kind of month the lineups are all
over town were one-man shows mm-hmm Josh
wolf had cheese the game included me
everybody was doing one big show ah
because there was a new way to get your
story after huh God were the days of Oh
Adam you want a TV show well tell me in
your act about you being the dad
you hit the softball practice and
describe your home life to be on stage
right last night I had a couple days ago
we had on be able to Daily Show we were
about to talk about what happens to
people would they move here mm-hmm
some people take the material that they
brought here do they stay true
themselves and they do that material
other materials your agent gets to you
says listen you got a deal with CBS this
is the material you have to do I don't
get comic that for years was a CBS shop
and CBS's contract he couldn't say that
he was gay on stage oh he couldn't even
say it anytime okay so this is 20 years
ago
guys it was a different [ __ ] game
yeah so yeah that 97 to 2000 is a little
bit of a change in that 90 70 to about
2005 then the deal stopped yeah I had
that made the game a little bit more
even what was going on when a guy like
me would be in Boston
he had a great 15 minutes this happened
to him for about three years three or
four years and it was a very frustrating
time for all the comics and for Congress
I was very frustrated with it but there
was nothing I could do
the only things I could do a by that was
had few options think about it or be
funny exact keyboardist or fouled wall
moody get buried and being funny so
there was a thing here that if you were
a good-looking male or a good-looking
girl what he ate and you had 13 minutes
so I would go to Boston and the Boston
comedy club would put up there 13 open
mic there's a late saw and if I fell in
love with Lee's look I would take Lee
and hide him make him signing the
contract then take you to Montreal hype
you up hype you up and I would even hire
a publicist for you for three months to
hype you up a month before Montreal so
by the time you got to Montreal they
were all that and watch this amazing at
least SIA and then it became a bidding
war okay I became a bidding war so next
thing you know Lisa ATS got a check in
the mail for 750,000
and he's got a commitment from [ __ ]
ABC to do a TV show right okay now you
signed the paperwork you get the
showrunner you get the writers did you
write it you write the first draft they
give you notes you write the second
draft they give your board ups boom you
write the third draft you submit it down
after three months you got a call your
pilot's getting shot what are we talking
about this is what the process was
yeah still ends down no now do you know
how much time that is by the time you
get the deal so the part of being shot
now a couple of years later years okay
guess what you deal is over yeah after a
year all right
that was a so now they've already got to
do Lisa yet so now yeah you got 750,000
you can pay the agent you paint a
manager you're a starlet you got a new
flavor
what but guess what I can't do that
which yeah because you're you got I
can't have mine yeah but they would
spend but they would so now they would
you're a [ __ ] clamp yeah you got me
for 600,000 yeah but let's say it's a
network right whatever one you were
saying let's say CBS all of them were
doing 14 almost 20 pilots a season
spending you know 20 30 million dollars
a year hoping that one becomes that
hundred million dollar a year machine
you know becomes CSI or becomes whatever
so like that doesn't exist anymore
where they're all doing 15 16 pilots
every Network realize in 2004 that they
were picking the wrong comics all right
comics did not have the chops
these 13 14 minute you bit of comics 20
minute comedy comedy mm-hmm
they realized that did not have the
chops to go into a room did you deal
with these people and it build a system
they don't know this is number two and
then you have the biggest thing to
overcome
once you get the pilot now that could
connect mm-hmm he's never acted before
in his life you know they didn't prep
you me
I'm a bad engine i side I haven't
catered to a [ __ ] one-year deal
ABC gets a call and says listen every
Network show put to having Aaron Cain on
every network shop puts having didn't
[ __ ] George Cody Staton Rosie yeah no
life he are but before he are he was a
Roseanne like we carry he was at the
boyfriend assumption like that he was
something you all got a start in this
one wave before he develops around well
yeah you know you look back and you go
so what were my Clooney years oh yeah
that's right they were a 2001 through
three Comedy Store guest star on Bernie
Mac speaking part on you not I mean
those are my Clooney and crazy and then
you know then once they realized they
were pick up the room comics they
stopped giving deals long together yeah
that's what I felt that was perfect
because no nobody was getting like that
was like oh five or six right no nobody
was getting lied to me boy so now
oh poor kid would hang himself but see
what I was also looking at was how much
the world had changed that in that era
because networks wanted to stay away
from politics because it was just to
device people were divided was over the
war was like at its peak in like oh four
oh six oh six was really bad that's when
Bush was like did the surge and then you
know he was kind of a lame duck after
that and and you know and then Obama
calm winds right but I'm just saying
that those last years of Bush people
were like outraged it was political it
was crazy like if we didn't have what we
had today you would look back and go man
those were some crazy political times
there I remember doing comedy during the
recount when Bush won and beat Gore they
doing a recount in Florida everybody had
like recount jokes you know about you
know poking the ballots and but like
people would be burnt out on all the
news too so it was uh it was a weird
time politically to figure out like
what's what's the difference between
people who they they come here to hear
our point of view versus people
come and just want to get away from
everything and here you know evergreen
jokes about you know fat jokes that's
the tenth let's pretend B this is what
people forget you know Herbie walks
around thing now we live in Tamara was
times right now that we're living in
time what do you think it was like when
Kennedy was present mm-hmm he was
[ __ ] Marilyn Monroe and opposing this
and opposing it
we've never been happy guys who the
president is never has there been a for
years where everybody is completely
happy so I leave that [ __ ] alone yeah
because nobody's ever happy no and now
it's building like it's building and
it's building a little bit more it's
building every little bit more nobody's
ever happy you know we think that the
glory days or when Eisenhower was he
everything yeah I mean a kid Nixon
resigning am I'm crying like a [ __ ] that
we lost our president I'm saying I
didn't [ __ ] know I didn't you know it
was Watergate
so the all that [ __ ] there's always been
thermal we just don't know we think that
we live in the worth of it we have no
idea people are we you know I still
remember going to grab the school where
once a week who had a drill to go to the
basement because we're gonna get bombed
by the rush right right the downstairs
it was old cans of corn and [ __ ]
bread that had mold on it and you had a
cyclical arm and no windows [ __ ] in a
room you know they were called
underground shelters every building when
you walked in how to have a sign that
said underground shop in that dang
[ __ ] water and old [ __ ] tanks you
know we don't remember we've always been
in a conflict with this time we just
take this cut this conflict everything
is a little bigger today because of the
media and the internet right we just
don't have three people telling your
story
we have thousand people telling
everybody
2,000 people that sit there all day and
pick up the scab all day yeah for
Americans to watch that get sucked in
yeah somebody put something today other
things and they put this has always
killed me and I didn't learn this too I
was 27 and I'm gonna drop it on your
[ __ ] right now I'm you plan on
doing anything with your life if you
really plan on doing anything with your
life if you're serious
really serious about doing anything with
your life um I need to think about
something but I didn't figure my I was
27 I grind him about I grind everybody
about it okay
football is great I got no problem with
you unless you paint your face like that
idiot yes yeah yeah the [ __ ] Rams
game and sat there like the Indian when
they threw little in the water the 60s
with that picture Indian he sat there
with a little T it yeah pulling like a
San Diego charge your face why would you
do something like that they got in the
Train with a bunch of people throwing
[ __ ]
I would never commit I just wear a shirt
and you're [ __ ] going you cheer for
whoever you like but they get dressed up
a grind hey wait I'm gonna have ink in
your face get a [ __ ] life
well yeah today somebody put a picture
up and I must say this whether people
like it or not or what they think of me
or what they don't think I'm because
this is what my reality was today
somebody put a picture up oh who do you
think will win the fight
but at least I am against Burton
whatever and I put down while we even
think about that about how much free
time no in a fight a fight like how much
free time do you have the day that you
have to think about that that's when I
love them some come up we go who's gonna
win the next you will see cry Caribbean
huh double point about feeding my family
today yeah that's what I'm seriously
yeah and that's a Battaglia I've had
when I was when I was 27 years old a
black guy in prison I'd never forgetting
you sometimes at night after roll call
act like you weren't allowed to go out
of your barracks
but you were loved to sit in front and
smoke a cigarette and if you had
insomnia
you never walk dance it was it uh
mosquitoes as long as it wasn't dead
[ __ ] black dudes jumping up and down
listen to Bobby Brown don't write cruel
they didn't give a [ __ ] a white bikers
if you went out there by yourself and
you couldn't sleep if a guard walked by
he'd go you okay in you again I just
can't sleep and walk away you know that
you're not smoking and what that black
guy sat next to me I'll never forget he
worked on me in the kitchen
and he was a nice enough guy and I asked
him one of my stupid typical white
[ __ ] questions that only I would
think how I'm ever suddenly told me from
faced with dire you have a great sense
of holding useless information like
somebody told me to my face
Treasury is like yeah you're like the
it's information doesn't really matter
if you okay you know it really doesn't
matter like we as young men we think
like it doesn't matter at the another
war it doesn't you're not impressing me
with that [ __ ] about this or that
he'll never forget he said to me I think
if you put as much time into thinking
this dumb [ __ ] as you get your life
together you really [ __ ] bad
[ __ ] and I never liked looking
at him and getting ready to say [ __ ] you
and I went to bed and I thought about
what he said and well I've changed that
moment a black convict that had eight
years left on his sentence said that to
me and the guy was like a model of a
great he was a great cook whatever the
[ __ ] he did in the kitchen yeah and I
told this kid that well now because I
put down you have time to think about
this really this is what you're datin
system you have time to think of this
bought this [ __ ] hand job
hmm and then a bunch of people answered
back and Ikes and I said Eddie I'm not
putting you down
that was an Italian I have when I was a
weak sack of [ __ ] and it took somebody
to town that's why I don't mind [ __ ] I
call those mine flux this town is filled
with mine [ __ ] yeah well if you accept
him when we first got here it was cast
net you signed with an agent you gotta
be a part of cast that then three years
later you gotta be a part of this then
four years then he'll be a part of this
and ain't years lady I do all and you
know at the end of the week you don't
have to do nothing you got to adapt all
you got to do this [ __ ] get up on
stage as many times you can tonight keep
that chitter-chatter mmm
of those comics the negative then I
should be at the store I was telling
some Joey Diaz couldn't follow Joe Rogan
you know he sucks I watch this guy's
look special he sucked mm-hmm just focus
I was some of those guys that my
favorite part of life is going to the
store an hour before my set the original
not the man who the original
get the [ __ ] stones I mean even to the
boiler taking like a half a xanax tongue
and knowing that I'm up in an hour and I
will sit back there and I will get
sucked in by those four comics and I
will learn more yeah I watching those
four comics now and I hate when a comet
comes up to me it ruins it
don't even say how well just sit next to
me and I will hear you like that my eyes
don't ask me if I'm payin ya don't say
[ __ ] nothing because that's all you
should be worried at man as Americans we
have so many things to try to throw us
off our game yeah when you come up to me
you know can you believe this mm-hmm
investigation I just laugh because they
just got you yeah they just got you they
just got you to do exactly what they
wanted to do to take your mind off the
ball mmm the twenty minutes that's what
kind of what they want but you know the
first time two things one the first
mitzi give me a spot after I'd showcased
she threw me on some show that was on in
the main room so she put me on in this
and I think maybe I'm ed and Jay were
producing the show and like to you know
99 and and then it was a 15-minute spot
or something like that anyway I was like
geez you know that's like um I thought
you died you know she'd had me in the
original room before that but anyway so
she puts me on in the main room then she
gives me a spot I don't know how did you
get past what was the process for you I
was in the belly room and Barnhardt's
and then you know I think I got in front
of MIT Siana
on a showcase night once when I was
doing comedy maybe a few months and then
a couple months after that she talked to
Maz was already a regular and she met a
med producing I'm showing a show in the
main room he was like producing
promoting a show out of the main room I
think with Jay Davis and she discovered
he was an Arab and then she was like Oh
is there any more and they're like yeah
you know Maz knew me so then you know
Maz recommended me I get in front of her
then she gives me his spot on like a
Thursday
in the main room and then she has me
open the OL are on Friday night at 9:00
p.m. on a Friday night and I'm like okay
amazing and I show up don't know how to
open the original room
I don't know how to open the show in the
Irish I study nigh start a comedy in
October to December you know so I just
go into my material too fast people are
sitting down they still hadn't gotten a
drink and nothing was you know because I
was just kind of like throwing up didn't
know how to bring it all together so I
got [ __ ] just basically it was a bomb
but it wasn't even like they were
listening it was like I felt like I was
just the worst experience in my life you
know so I go back and sit the back of
the room you were on that lineup and
[ __ ] holtzman I think went out late but
somewhere in there I just watched comic
after comic and tell Paul Mooney going
on now Paul Mooney looks so clean that
night he was wearing white and a hat and
everything and I was like what did I do
wrong
how come I couldn't get one laugh on all
the jokes that I have that I've you know
so uh that was the night that I sat and
watched every comedian and then she kept
giving me spots and every night I would
just sit there and watch you guys you
know I spent quite an education and she
made me work the door - so yeah yeah how
would she I'd have a spot and I'd worked
the door learn learn learn the original
room this is she her whole vision was
for it to be a college for it and you
know it really is like I didn't realize
the time - I shot I'm dying up here that
watched on a plane and it was like wow
now I remember what she stood for mm-hmm
well I stood for and it kind of Strayer
me back out about the store like it kind
of she had rules she
these weird comes nothing to her it was
a method to event instead really means
Barnhart the Sunday being like Sunday
nights for as Adams night she wouldn't
really give him a spot here and there
maybe in the old war if he asked or
something but she was like you just are
always gonna have Sunday nights for some
reason she thought that he was like
Southern Baptists you know revivalists
you know and Sunday night the you know
would be a good Sunday's you know Church
kind of thing I think in her mind she
was like gave Sunday to Adam you know
you watch red bow mmm then you go is
that part were that they the cops are
like you whatever possessed God to bring
a man like me involved awesome that guy
walk something goes God didn't make
Rambo I'm a grand ball that's the
colonel that come because now in
hindsight now with the hindsight I see
what she was doing well that was she got
me I was doing calmly six years but I'm
paid before like I was doing kind of me
six years but I'm paid before they had
no success like I wasn't having success
or out of town but I started going in
there it was the same process you know
you just bothered you're just going down
to the body up you just going on I
didn't know David Tribble ones you ever
get trouble yeah let you live on those
that's how you that's how that's a
different the best thing is to be
coupled regular at the store and then do
a tribute that's what I did all I know
is what I did Wow
Kelly Kirsten hooked me up with it I had
to thirty minutes I had a car who drove
uh I had a car so I always end up
driving and Hulu they have minors Brad
reader brand reader from like Carolina
hey you ever been do you've been to
South Carolina like blue blue ribbon
fair and I'm like well the [ __ ] asks a
question like that you ever been to the
blue county fair and a [ __ ] Savannah
you like all those triple runs
was the headliner guys funny but you
know come on yeah and you know God bless
Brad these jokes get burned into your
brain like you don't remember the person
but ladies joke to the haunt you for the
rest of your life oh my god
there was one comic and I out never
remember his name right now but he was
great guy and he was an older comic and
he you probably know him remember him
but uh [ __ ] I can't remember his name
but everybody else besides the one that
I drove around with was like you know
you just you know you just try to be I
was just happy to be there
watch it you are when you're a feature
the middle of Montana you're at the
middle of Montana and you're just happy
to have a gate and happy to have a hotel
room yeah and happy to pick up $50
you're like I'm so happy about this man
I could piss myself
yeah I'm like you look out the window
and there's your town 89 I just had like
a tiny little bit of weed yeah you know
you don't know what it's like to wake up
look at your map get out of the room
yeah look at the Sun it's like 282 money
yep there was no GPS Nellis roadsides
and you just got in your car and in
those days you just stopped to pee I
stopped when the tank was empty
yeah that's it that's it that was my
rule yeah drive in between 10:00 you do
that job between Denver Salt Lake I do
every and then Salt Lake to Tahoe oh
that northern route oh the snow no
chains of in your [ __ ] tires because
that every trip will run some kind of
kid Sudheer oh god some comic is not
gonna make it hit a deer trouble still
lying to the Y where is it stolen organ
I gotta get in touch with him he's
booked no no God no I thought bless him
because you know he gave me a change oh
he gave a he helped me so much
he helps you why you dueled it you get
robbed yeah well he's a dirty [ __ ]
thief or that lovely fruit because
that's what you're supposed to do to
people you're robbing yeah you're
robbing I didn't know how much you tie
your league you're going on the road
this weekend but you're sleeping on the
floor next to the jab
yeah that's it his Oh payment you
teacher it has to be getting 100 bucks a
show minimum where the triple would now
I mean cuz when I was doing it it wasn't
even a hundred but it'll be like six in
a row of like you know sixty eighty
bucks or whatever it was and then now to
break even you had to be tight Tribble
paid $85 is set you picked up 50 and you
got a check mail to you for 35 oh the
guy in Texas paid a buck 25 to feature
and the headliner 225 so when the budget
was 400 he kept to write the budget was
6 plus they pay for around for two
people then there was a company in not
Montana moved to one of Nebraska Oh
crawl and they Co had learned me and
they were paying 150 asset yeah
but dole Bryant as good as creative
creative at the table was on the East
Coast
underneath Charlotte and they booked
Charlotte into West Virginia all the way
to the islands Barbados all those
Caracas the whole thing years gotta work
spotless clean on the are you say one
word they squat you off the stage a ship
helicopter comes get you clean out your
room you'll double your creative run
again oh and they make it clear before
you go understand so they would have a
Bermuda week you go for two weeks 500 a
week but you can bring your family well
no she's over the Bahamas Bahamas
Bermuda whatever you need to do two
weeks that's how good creative was
creative paid 175 to feature and 250 to
add line with the same amount of driving
in between the turbo runs but only in
the south you go a deep deep in into a
barn there's a fence up yeah they throw
bottles a just let the Blues Brothers
know like in front of you
[ __ ] yeah Clark subdued Clark's Tim
subsidy and a fence up to like there was
two places that have
fences and trouble runs there was a
Clarkston no it created that would like
West Virginia on top of a ping-pong
table then if you said the word [ __ ] you
got fined $50 so if you got 175 you said
[ __ ] once I said the word [ __ ] I just
ran with it yeah that's it because they
only charged me 50 anywhere buddy get
25th buzz we got twenty [ __ ] off these
20 this $50 bill and then there was a
place in Craig Colorado that had like a
wall with the glasses I think I'm
looking at they tell you if the place
got active just to run to your room and
lock the door
but that's what people only stand is
people go on those they come back they
decide that's it you you that let you
decide yeah it showed you you know but
that's this is a point that I've always
made about female comics because what
female in general is gonna be in the
middle of Nebraska or [ __ ] Montana
driving around with the headliner they
just met and they picked them up from
Reno at the airport and been driving
like it just seems like it doesn't lend
itself to anything that girls are like
taught and raised
you know women will do it no control the
tour trip will take care of the way ya
know as well I know a lot of women I've
never heard a complaint on a trip never
never I never heard in turn triple takes
care of his girls the whole town takes
care of the girls cuz I went on a tour
what a girl would time she was no Miss
America hmm I mean you had to have 20
[ __ ] cocktails to even think either
ass but we protect her you know there
was there was thanks when we went to
clubs yeah they were a little scary you
know you know that movie uh what's the
movie with the girls softball team
Madonna they're all legal their role
what's the chick that's really ugly
Marlon Marla
remember were they for me no but would
they remember that dude what's the dude
that they had the comedy club up at the
[ __ ] uh up at the [ __ ] Universal
Center what's his Lovitz Jon Lovitz
plays yeah that movie
yeah there's a scene where he goes in to
see a girl and the father brings a row
but she's the ugliest thing in the world
with all this [ __ ] that was this
headliner I worked with huh
but bro there were guys still hit yeah
it sounds like we look at guys I mean
I'm not putting just woman down with
this she was a sweet all right well I
would have called Georgia more joy yeah
yeah I was what particularly who died
who took me on a two-week tour and she
was a voluptuous woman and I watched her
I never thought a bang and uh you know I
knew was I knew from day one that it's
tough enough to do terribly yeah then
why are you trying to bang a headliner
out all right so I worked with this one
lady who was a heavyset lady from Denver
she passed recently I forget her name
I'm sorry I worked with a woman out of
Portland that's the woman I'm telling
you though it was Marla maples would
like the water but that's what made her
funny yeah and then I worked I took a
girl of the road as a feature mm-hmm I
watched over yeah because and I would
tell her yeah well then go upstairs you
got to be a favor
you got to go up because I'm not leaving
you downstairs in my room thinking about
you all that mmm I don't like going on
the road with people make me nervous
nervous yeah we people well I'm gonna go
out with these guys come in for second
look at the shape of these guys yeah you
gotta get the car motor yeah I'm not
going through that you get in the car
with two just take your [ __ ] shift
local dogs you know I'm old school you
can't get it done and I wouldn't but one
night in one of those towns up north I
got into a car with these dudes and
loads of the promoter pulled up next to
me was could Joey let me talk to you for
a second he goes get out of the car with
those dudes in little Rob you don't
gonna sell you drugs I took them to the
zombie drugs mmm yeah I mean cuz that's
kind of the I actually got into an
argument with an open mic or who I'm
friendly with but do you guys ever look
back at those gigs being 12 hours away
from LA we're 18 hours away like you say
women might not feel say if I don't
I don't think I can win a fight legged
like yeah
no it's dangerous for anybody to be
somewhere it's not like you guys are
looking back like [ __ ] I shouldn't have
been there
no I I've never thought of that but I
think that in the country is safer than
you know you think it means
people everywhere nice I [ __ ] ran
into George McGovern in [ __ ] Missoula
you know in Montana he's like out there
with his family how big trouble what
week's did you do I didn't like three
different like kind of sections he likes
a no run the bazzill run yes yes there
was like a six-week thing it seemed like
yes this is six weeks you can you'll put
you out there please don't wait for the
rub and so you get really good yeah you
get really good it's an ugly seven weeks
well what you're in the road of it you
just do it I did a broke I didn't what
zero mud no bank account so who drove I
drove you had a car he drove he kept it
on the budget that he was paying I
refused a second car with people snacks
like I didn't smoke cigarettes then see
you we're not gonna get my car if you
smoke cigarette huh huh you know the
music that's I'm that's what anybody so
for the first six months I did well you
show up yeah headliner did his own thing
yeah I quality they would they have
money to get picked up I put his name
yeah yeah I don't like people to call it
me yeah we'll take the middle ring now
after a year of doing that I started
going out with people who I knew mmm why
could go up to go do you mind taking 25
hours less and that's co-headlining yeah
at least wit together we just split at
least we're happy right right I got a
wall we smoke joints we could write
jokes together yeah we could split rest
you know suppose the rest yeah
Saturday Sunday Monday so that you get
the hotel room by yourself for a tea
yeah we split for tea you know that's
that's what they're fun when yank your
friend with you when you're near that
point I never really yeah I never got to
headlining a triple run I go ahead I am
happiest I ever did Wow I think I I have
lined a couple like nights when somebody
hits a deer
something doesn't bacon my Kilcoy yeah
Ruby go you have a stretch you know so
he just decides to eat things as a
headliner I mean there's no inside the
tapes listen with you when you first
start comedy that's the first thing they
tell you and in nine different states on
this side of the country honestly right
now I wonder if he'd let me outline yeah
like a couple of spots it's not gonna be
a lot of money it you know you got a
badger no but I could go out there for
an hour from the some natives from Idaho
you never know like right now there's
the only I would do a trip boy the good
thing is I could take a flight the
beginning of it so let's say the first
night would be purple of origin okay I
would fly into Portland and rent the car
yeah and then drive some and drive to
the other would drive to the other would
drive to the fourth one yeah and then
that night get in the car and fly out of
bent out of all you can't fly out of bed
you got to fly to Portland to go back
Portland the next day you're not gonna
but people don't realize is like this
guy lightly like a [ __ ] cause Lee Lee
has to do the drive from here at the
bend
no that's how you'd that how much
morning could triple actually make on a
night like how much well you gotta
remember that he goes into his colonic
right he's not gonna go to a bar in LA
okay so he's gonna go to a bar
that's [ __ ] 2,000 miles away fine
civilization people are coming through
and there's these little spots he gets
them all but he has to he has to get a
lot of wood you know when you did it
there was six hour drive isn't it yeah
in between the 13 you're out there this
place is that there's no lights there's
no street signs maybe you're [ __ ] out
there yeah if you break down they
they'll tell you make sure you gas up at
this location
cuz you're not gonna see a guest a
straight out yep you know what a car
ya know we got a chance together learn
all these things like there's a route we
used to take from LA to used it we could
do that in 22 hours yeah I was doing
that with Ralphie Bay Ricky we were
doing in 22 hours but you better gas up
in El Paso [ __ ] did you ever put a gas
tank in the car like an extra of
emergency no less you do it Jewish
lightning this is
[ __ ] you I wish you to burn some things
out down then you put an extra yeah how
do I guess leaving gone all right
anything could happen
ah but that run from El Paso to Houston
mm there's like a 6 hour run where you
don't see civilization yeah and you got
into music don't come in the radio
stations don't come in uhmmm also know
you hear is like praise Jesus
yeah the Lord seems you stopped by
Presbyterian Church of [ __ ] and you
know like wow I thought I wanted to do
comedy these are all that these are all
the things that when you come home with
a triple one of a sudden they're like
what just happened yeah I just spent
eight gas tanks I filled up my car
twelve times I drove fifty [ __ ]
thousand miles and for what four [ __ ]
four times eighty five hours yeah and
then but you did you feel like you
advanced in your comedy like you know
did you find you had to start talking
about other things or some things but I
mean what it was what was it that you
figured out because it's that point I
was just happy that I would try any joke
I can think of not knowing my voice I
would just write anything that wouldn't
be connected no I didn't have a voice
duh you know yes I didn't have a voice
either I had no voice at that time I was
doing comedy maybe three four years and
I was just throwing out things out there
and then depending on the rooms because
a lot of rooms rewarded yes he I'm
Mormon are you happy my mom's side his
background was Mormon so that was the
thing as I was always talking about that
and I was feeling like cuz I would grew
up in Utah when I was a kid you know we
left when I was you know nine and uh and
so the Mormon [ __ ] would they would
nobody ever dug Mormon jokes
who the [ __ ] does makes fun of more like
nobody even gets it in LA if you talk
about Mormons it's so funny man nobody
knows anything about Mormons but when I
got out there I felt like things were
working for what you get
Utah there's places in Northern
California hmm that they'll tell you
have the itinerary it's gonna be a
heavy-duty morbid yeah constituency I
got banned from Logan Utah because it's
kind of like conservative college town
and it was a bad bad show and so much it
turned into like an open mic and
somebody else told a joke and then I put
the Mikey and I started [ __ ] around
with them and we were cussing and the
guy didn't like it no go take the
[ __ ] mic off on you yeah turned into
like Street jokes and [ __ ] and then he
was like so uh and I didn't care because
if you lose that job who cares but so
it's that you know what it is it's the
thing about being able to fail and back
to the second chances you know how
conversation started about first chance
second chance third chance like you you
can't do comedy
unless you've failed real good you know
unless you really kind of start it out
like you know on a triple thing like I
didn't have 30 minutes when I had to do
30 minutes no you know so you doesn't
have 30 minutes so do 30 minutes yeah so
I think the same thing with lifting
weights yeah if I say to you I'm gonna
put 225 on the pound you're gonna go
don't do it cuz I can't do it what if I
don't tell you it's 225 I tell you with
185 when you lift it right you know
Jesus Christ I looked at 225 but here's
the other thing if you fail you failed
pushing it right this is a good place to
fail where you're doing something so
you're going to fail and if you don't
fail then you're not really learning
rights this whole thing this whole cycle
that you have to go through when you're
like trying to crack the code you know
because I wasn't killing a crowd I'd
have a one funny joke it wouldn't be
able so like to fail the the the the
surviving to the next day be like okay
last night sucked tonight was better
that was bad and then you start to feel
that cycle of like how do you keep it on
the on the higher side how do you keep
cutting out the fat how do you keep
cracking the code okay so you started in
what year 99 no see you at the store 99
you
and then in 2003 you started the axis of
evil yeah well you don't calm me for
years
at this point yeah well no it yeah it
was like October of 99 no I got picked
up as a regular December of 99 so mm all
right so December who don't know okay
but I was doing comedy that you know
eight nine months leading up to that
right and you were still adornment I
wasn't a doorman yet talk until 2010
December 99 you know and then I got
picked up and then from there and I and
I got and I got grouped in with Ahmed
Maas she I think tried to have Sebastian
and Ernst and Tripoli she thought
everybody all of us were Mediterranean
like Middle Eastern that's how crazy she
was [ __ ] and she took control of Ahmed
and Jay Davis's show and she says you
it's gonna be all these people and all
these you know and like Sebastian and
Maserati regulars and then she picked up
Brett and Tripoli I think we was regular
then and uh you know cuz we're house
that night she made sure be a regular
overall yeah this is the original room
yeah and uh anyway so then there was
this whole thing with her trying to put
middle eastern Mediterranean things
together this is in 99 she loved ethnic
things well she said that that was the
ethnicity that hadn't been explode all
that [ __ ] yeah she should make the main
room like she tried to get me to do the
Cuban thing to dress up like all right
with a cigar all right and then she got
Cory qualms would actually make the call
and get a Cuban restaurant to cater it
well they did it one time but I got out
of it I was out of town
oh [ __ ] so cuz I didn't want to do
something with her and fail and then not
get spots in the original room I saw
that you got involved with her in a
bunny venture and it failed you are out
of sight out of mind he Jewish just like
me we failed leads around you the kids
at that we had a room for awhile you
[ __ ] blow it now I'm not giving you
spots so whenever she was suggested to
her a certain theme room with
I would always play this I would tell
her yes that night give her a kiss Megan
another spot but then I knew she'd
forget by next time I see it yeah so I
would avoid her for a few days
I would really avoid her until and then
she mentioned it twice nightly she had a
problem but she never really she bothers
me about the Fidel a few times one
strong aware of luck in the whole
fatigues of the Hat she was into trying
to get people to do weird like I think
she was [ __ ] with them I wonder if
she told kind of Kirsten she should wear
a short pink wig yeah I think that she
was going to see what your reaction was
if you bow down to her did she tell you
to go [ __ ] yourself yeah so that's what
I always took from her maybe knowing her
when she told you to do something you
didn't do it except for one person that
is the the funniest [ __ ] thing ever
when I got to the store there were a few
people who were big shots in the head
but there was this one guy that hung out
with a big shot in which she made him a
regular she made him a regular one
condition that he played a guitar so he
lied to her
he went up then in the guitar when she
was around he play the guitar and when
she wasn't he wouldn't bring the guitar
as things and have an awful Bobby Oh
without the guitar without the guitar he
kept bawling so what the hell but they
night she walked in and I'm gonna be
sitting in that area if she walked in
while at hours on stage and the tower
was up deck kill this is ah this has to
be died be there at hours [ __ ] man
rip I wish I was the one on a bud day
and who has to go up next but this Bora
but in those days Mitchie then coming up
one days hmm
she just happened to come as a tower
Stan was in the back giggling
at I was doing a bit about playing
whatever went down and he had a keel on
the plane we were dying and then this
kid went up there and tried to do his
okey-doke act and was she he walked off
he didn't see her
she pulled the besides she knows the
next time you come here you better bring
the guitar with you so I hear this and I
go downstairs and home say nothing about
a half hour later Mitzi leaves and he's
in the back talking big [ __ ] I mean he's
talking big [ __ ] that he's never gonna
[ __ ] bring the guitar again
he's on man [ __ ] Mitzi she doesn't know
what she's talking spice she's a [ __ ]
idiot
huh and I'm back there and I wanted to
smack this [ __ ] yeah you know
but he was running with like a pretty
deep crowd had to sell it by my business
and yes yeah because at that time I was
already at that time it takes people
years to shut their [ __ ] mouth like
it really does it takes people years
something shut that mouth especially
when somebody tells you something that
is good for you and you still go against
it because of your stupid selfishness it
takes years it took me a year to have to
learn Mitzi system mmm and I applied to
it do you follow me and then I'd see
people that was smarter than Mitzi and
they got like Minzy just had this system
and when she told you something she
meant it like the day she pulled me
aside you know I love you but don't
think you'd think I thought what I
didn't take my [ __ ] right I think I
think about what's after that [ __ ] you
didn't [ __ ] around bitching is
everyone's rule though Bitsey at the
people I grew up with yeah [ __ ] she was
from Milwaukee she was raised in Miami
understood when somebody pulls you aside
you from Milwaukee with somebody pulls
you aside they go to you this is what
you do from now on
and you don't do it she would either
stop talking to you yeah we're just nuts
to give you spots right which is what I
learned
hold on and we started to talk about
that too it's like just don't [ __ ] say
[ __ ] I sure can do your [ __ ] say a
[ __ ] word
nobody asks you yeah for your [ __ ]
opinion I bet he's gonna continue I
never [ __ ] opinion I never once asked
her or said anything I was a grown man
[ __ ] never you're right about her
telling me little things at the end of
my sets as I was walking out and she
touched me
yeah the way she would touch me she was
letting me know
then my her telling me that she cared
like I'm out here to put you down
I'm just not either you'd be a lot
better car became you did this a lot of
compost woke up her [ __ ] saying have
a drink and go off go off about what
bits he said or somebody else told you
thank God no yeah I know when somebody's
give me the right information when Mitzi
was in the room I always wanted to do my
my best I was always like I always want
to do I always want to do so good you
know added pressure but I was always
able to let it go and be like yeah you
know she's been in the room where I'm
performing a lot after a while she
wanted to see you buff to see if she
wanted you to go on a via character she
made me come up to her house once she
wanted to rewrite my act or she wanted
to help me write my act is after 9/11
and uh cuz we're all doing Arab stuff
for like since dis since January of 2000
we were doing like she was trying to put
this Middle Eastern thing together and
so on what does that January February
March April May June July August you
know nine months and then that should
happen so then she we were all you know
trying to figure out how to react to it
the best reactions I remember Stanhope
I remember Eddie Griffin I remember like
the first people who got you know when
the store opened that Thursday or
whatever it was closed right it was
closed Tuesday and then they reopened it
Wednesday night they closed it at that
Tuesday they reopened it Wednesday so I
think I was there on you know Thursday I
was there the whole weekend I was
working the door and you had a spot and
then but uh she put me on Saturday night
in the belly room and then that week
she's like come in the house I wanna you
know well right we'll go through your
act and stuff mostly she was I think so
yeah probably masterpiece no
no I should I should have tried but we
cuddled a little you know like you know
we got we got physical we we touched you
know I made her I try to soothe her I
rubber back a little bit or whatever she
wanted and then whole oh she at this
point
68 70s really yeah
no no no they fight these mid 60s we're
talking early 2000s yeah well that first
brother Shinda intercept you're still
cute
she's still petite and cute yes even
cute you could tell yeah she was a bomb
you know I can't lie the I I was missing
the love of a mom all right so when she
would pull me aside and touch me and Tom
be certain things I got so mad like the
first to fight the Fidel [ __ ] and
something else she wanted me to do
something about I don't even know I I
didn't agree with but there were other
things she would tell me like Paul was
here but she told me once I'm not
waiting for the laughter mmm you control
your laughter wait for like she would
say little things to me yeah but getting
back to that story me by that point
after 18 months admits he told Tommy son
it was gold to them saying well if Mitzi
told me they'd have to eat there I
wouldn't eat that like Mitzi was [ __ ]
gold I would dare was also though times
where you were like Mitzi's the baseline
so whatever she says is that's that's
good that's what the book says to do
that's it that's what it's liable words
that's how the rule that's right had a
plan that you had gone [ __ ] idea she
was actually in her brain but that's not
to say that the book is always right so
one time there was this [ __ ] gig that
I didn't really want to do it was kind
of far away I don't remember what it was
it was just kind of this thing kind of
got me on the hook to maybe do but I
didn't really want to do it because
Mitzi's giving me really good spots
every night and I'm like I don't need to
go to someone off thing that it's kind
of shady what Lancaster yes in Lancaster
it was only for a couple hundred dollars
or some [ __ ] and I and I asked mitts yes
if Missy should I do this gig and she's
like no don't do any
gigs don't go on the road just stay here
and work out at the storm I was like all
right and I did you know I didn't do the
gig you know
but that resonated - cuz later on I was
like she doesn't care what that [ __ ]
thing would have paid you know if I told
her I said no no it's like ten fifteen
thousand dollars she she'd probably
agree with me and we'd have okay yeah
but don't do that
don't give him the material that they
want yeah but she thought the best thing
to do is to stay in town and work and
right in the store and at home when she
made me she made me on a Sunday and I
bent over to her and had tears in my
eyes and I told her I was haunted and
she's like save it oh she knows just
make sure you qualify sponsors we go I
can't go in four spots I have a
weekender brew the tea feathers I saw
looked at me look was take that week and
you're then gonna get a spot very good
yeah and I woke up Monday morning
hesitation at nine o'clock called
roosterteeth brothers or whatever the
club was Tommy tees
oh it was Tommy tees right it was it it
was like a 13-hour drive 300 bucks and
I'll never forget I go
she knows I'm passing you called scat
day four spots tomorrow oh you're so
handsome like they'd say go Mitzi oh I
can't call up the spots I got Tommy T
sick I was trying to be braggadocio in a
way like I didn't say I was gonna say
thing going on yeah I was trying to be
bragging does she like how I got Tommy
T's and she just looked at me and that
look said like oh it looks like you
cancel it again she gonna be doing spots
here all right
she didn't have to say it like yeah she
didn't even have to say it yeah I went
outside got my car went on the next one
I [ __ ] woke up call that club but
they want they yelled at me
how can you can so it's Wednesday yeah
you give them seed to five minutes I get
a [ __ ] scab all right I could think
so what's this move you got a trick up
and bury um [ __ ] man don't know I was
just gonna say that that all that that
group that you came in there with
because I remember like watching Bobby
Lee and Sanchez around mitzi Johnny
Sanchez with cassettes used to love
Sanchez like cracked her up to like the
bone like he did something to her that
she just always thought he was this guy
who was always like complaining and
yelling at her and [ __ ] and he would
play into it and then she would look at
Bobby and go like are you looking at me
and he'd say yeah and she'd be like
really like how do you see out of those
things she says to Bobby
anyway man I still remember the axis of
evil tour ok so so we were doing these
Middle Eastern shows and then yeah that
happened and uh-oh for a meta and I went
to the Edinburgh Festival and when
that's the first time we called it acts
of evil because it was called Arabian
Nights you know and then we changed it
to the accident and then two years later
we got a deal and we shot it for all you
know Comedy Central
what's-his-name over at Lovett Lovett on
no no levity levity yeah I forget
ability that was them you know and and
then so anyway then we toured and then
we went to the Middle East and then the
Middle East blow [ __ ] it was great and
then and then I got married and then I
had a baby and now I'm like she's 3
years old and my being out every night
doing comedy is if you know it's
different yeah so a useful tutorial
yeah I'm still doing dates I'm still
doing gigs I was just in Dallas this big
[ __ ] Labor Day thing that was amazing
was ten thousand Arabs it's outdoor
concert huge stage bunch of music so
like [ __ ] flies everywhere yeah
exactly
scarves and
long you see people in America you gotta
have a good time with this she's gonna
have a good time you know I still
remember you and are we going
head-to-head yeah for years about
Palestine he just wasn't Jew Ville when
[ __ ] he wouldn't even have a mother
[ __ ] he used to crack me about there
this guy at every opportunity he would
find a way to be insulting or call us
all animals or something you know and
he's like you know you don't treat
animals the same way as you keep treat
humans so you got to digestion debate
and you know at he would never not do
that to the point where you're like he
probably believes it at this point
because he's all he can ever do he can't
have the conversation without that so
over those years leads to a bit thing
you know Ari and I were always by God
loved each other see it like a remark at
you like keep him away from me yeah but
now go what the [ __ ] you guys are just
talking five minutes ago [ __ ] yeah I
wanted re be my counterpart because like
how often you're gonna get a [ __ ]
Palestinian in here you jus you know
what I mean how when are you gonna talk
about this like you have a Palestinian
you could just have family over there
you know I I just I was just there I
just did gigs in Ramallah this talk
about getting into a car you shouldn't
get in on a weird gig you know I'm
seventy-seven thousand miles away
this guy's like no come on let him smoke
me it was smooth he's getting this man
you know the other two comics are like
who is it
he's there like dude he's like a um he's
Palestine Nam Authority he's a captain
in the authority in the you know
military there okay we get in the car
with [ __ ] smoke we he's blasting music
he's like you guys want to drift he
starts burn
drifts around one of those [ __ ]
circles acting crazy doing donuts you
know high fives
good night see you next you know next
year in Ramola you know I mean sometimes
you get in the car and it's great all
I'm saying is you know we had a good
time yeah we had a good time we have a
good time you still get spots at the
store no not much
Messi's died really yeah yeah I got boy
yeah you still like you yeah I I don't
feel like I was very high in the pecking
order that night at the funeral you know
they were getting a lot of people
together to talk or get on you know get
up in the Oh or whatever I'm like you
know nobody was really asking me to come
and get on stage and tell them my story
good they're there yeah I was hanging
around with a while I've been talking
with so many people out outside but like
you know when they somebody comes in the
hallway and they're like looking for
comics and I'm like I'm right here you
know what I mean
I'm like I don't know I just I just been
quiet I've been quiet lately that's okay
you made you dudes you have nothing to
me nice I talked to Adam I still you
know it's fine everything's good health
yes let me back in there but it's so
funny though
I know 500 people listen to Mitzi and
for Madeline and all those 400 people
[ __ ] god yeah right
they're probably somewhere else I'm
gonna forget she told this lesbian girl
something one day this girl was [ __ ]
outside cursing at her and [ __ ] like
people used to take stuff too personally
when they work topic
yeah but this guy I'm talking about so
she tells him that to come back without
the guitar oh yeah woman sign I could do
a couple of blasts of coke
how about side and I'm watch this guy
holding court tell the people at MIT you
don't don't think about dick that he's
not gonna [ __ ] he refuses to kick
coward out there
mmm-hmm you know when I'm sitting there
looking all broke she's trying to teach
you something I don't know what it is
even at that point in my coked out 99
crazy open-mike mind cuz I was still
hoping Mike that no I know I was like
this dumb [ __ ]
it's questioning [ __ ] Jesus yeah
you're questioning like the Hells Angel
of Hell's Angel yeah and he disappeared
for like three months he went to other
places tried to come on then that Barbic
the Union - yeah and the bar next to it
where Dane Cook became a star Dublin dub
open double first open it wasn't Jay
Davies still all right it was Ben I'm
bad that I think he gave Dave yeah there
was like two or three of them yeah but
one of the first times they did it we
with over there and that kid was there
and I had a couple of wines ago could be
a couple cocktails and I'd invite the
kid particular boy maybe not like the
war was how he talked against Mitzi yeah
like how he was talking [ __ ] against MIT
6sv you are you're at the [ __ ]
Cowboys yeah did the fearless leader has
tongue giving you advice and you're
[ __ ] with her what what yeah so I went
up to him and I go how's life he goes
you know be life is great but I'm about
ready to come back economy store it's
time I mean you bring up the guitar back
I and he goes yeah it's trying to bring
that to your time with them straight in
the face I go if I was you you're so
[ __ ] bad you must don't bring a whole
one-piece [ __ ] band Tony but it
brings symbols which in a flute they're
not had this guy well I got like hey
that's how disrespectful I felt that she
sure yeah
don't you ever [ __ ] go out the
parking lot get my smack head twice I
[ __ ] just went off on him and they
held him back you know they held me back
I would have [ __ ] killed this kid in
99 I was out of my [ __ ] mind
yeah then about three maybe maybe six
months later I saw him at the store and
he had the guitar and I made my [ __ ]
thing and he had a couple cocktails
and his buddy had a cocktail and I had
hardly can bottle of my mm-hmm and I was
standing by the men's bathroom and they
were still they made me seven eight feet
away and as I was coming out of the
bathroom he said to be did you just go
with the bathroom door and a coke see
you could be funny and I know the funny
thing is I don't leave home to be fine
new coke after I get off stage you you
here we are you [ __ ] eat are you
[ __ ] nut head he's like [ __ ] you
let's go at it and before he stepped I
unleashed that bomb I really can add up
and it hit the wall behind those and hit
the other guy just ran away and I never
heard nothing about the next day I'm
driving to the store and I'm looking
front of coach of horses
the comic he was with was there I think
I mean I contacted okay well let me talk
to you yeah it was that thing last thing
I'm gonna do it me [ __ ] him yeah he's
not gonna get me in trouble again that's
like the tenth fight he's got it was a
nightmare
oh my yeah there was a lot of guys that
would go to store just to complain those
days I thought they had something they
imitated me to know it yeah because I
complained Woods I got put in my place
and I never [ __ ] complained again I
never [ __ ] heavy complainer I never
complained I was afraid to ask her for
like hey I'm mitsue I have a you know a
family dinner and I I got to go to
dinner I might not be able to go up
until later maybe yeah you know like I'm
available but I somebody know she didn't
know she refused it's like she refused
that if she gave you had a calling for
every night you said I have to go bring
your dad there bring she didn't give a
[ __ ] she told me that one to her office
time that she goes these [ __ ] comics
they don't want to be time expired but
then they make plans to be dinner comics
don't got a [ __ ] it's a no you don't
she used to unleash it in front of me
that I would look at no you're right you
don't do dinner I don't ever forget I do
the showcase and I made dinner plans and
I went to that garlic restaurant Hawk
right and I walked out of there smell
ice $22 this [ __ ] guy he's got flies
Jason yeah and let me tell you something
I showcase and the people came up to me
too shook my hand I didn't call me the
next station no chili then cuz I smelt
like a [ __ ] mycommerce bag that was
dead for four [ __ ] days yeah always
said it don't go out the denon before
you do Cammy I want your mind on Tommy
that's why she didn't serve food at the
combination like that she didn't like
people he have you girls are like no she
was rules a dark room with kind of a low
ceiling girls have to be serving drinks
and it has to be after dark
yeah right you know most of their rules
yeah she had rules right and you know
it's funny how the other day somebody
sent me a link some jerk-off that was
put me and Ari down and being a bunch of
the people and then they went into this
whole Comedy Store thing
about how economy store isn't really the
kind of you story so whatever I mean
what the [ __ ] are you talking about you
would survive three minutes just the
shock I know I know for a fact I could
see somebody and I know now from where I
was when I walked into the comedy store
who I thought I was in my head the first
six months without a pretty [ __ ]
situation all a little mess it's a mess
you just trying your best your messes a
he would be yeah you're just trying to
survive and you don't know if that's
your last spot left
right you don't know she just saw you
that's your last spot yeah that's a [ __ ]
that's PTSD that's why I was getting all
that [ __ ] blow and whatever the [ __ ]
I could do in those days yeah this is so
many different scenarios that are going
on you have to block out so many things
you have to just not think about but but
yeah man I always was comfortable with
Mitzi in the room I used to like it but
there was a time in when she was man you
know Tommy had Mitzi right and she had a
lot of dementia but by that time it was
no good she didn't recognize it's time
he got there it was the beginning of the
end tommy was missing that Tommy brought
the final death of [ __ ] well to me
shut everybody down the distort during
those years there was too much
controversy and it was different type of
controversy
it wasn't friendly controversy it wasn't
you me having a beef over a joke or
something you said it was a little bit
deeper you made comics running a ship
controlling lineups it was a deeper
darker time and he was lying to Mitzi
the whole time but she didn't know
whether it was Monday or Tuesday yeah so
he was the only conduit to Mitzi telling
Erin what Mitzi said even though Mitzi
didn't know implanted she was on so
that's when I bought out I go something
that's not here the one day I walked in
there and she looked at me weird it was
like 2007 and it was mm-hmm I think I
did yes I still was doing blow after I
left the store but I wanted there to
pick up a check and I saw her on the way
down mm-hmm and I saw something I saw
something that I
it was weird a little bit but walking
out that door and I said to myself I'm
not coming back to this place and I'm
calling Rogan I remember when you said
it Rogan I'm advising you don't go back
to this place yeah Rogan was hot he was
on fear factor and he told me he didn't
give a [ __ ] what I had to say that he
was gonna go down there and maybe a
month or two after that he got thrown
that mmm and Mitzi called Rogan and told
him he was okay I don't know what the
exact story is it was [ __ ] though who
went against Rogan because he wanted the
other [ __ ] [ __ ] said he's gonna
star of the store Saint Joe's been safe
so he chose Mencia and the other [ __ ]
[ __ ] so that's what happened at that
time period by that time period I knew I
was done I remember you told me once on
the back steps you were like no man I'm
down around here you know you young guys
you know blah blah and you were like it
wasn't too long after that were you
really yes this one around if you're at
Michigan you have to stick to your
[ __ ] nails
in life and in connolly you know all
those years of my addiction he is but I
still had it sharp I was still booking
movies I was still getting up that's my
time and money
[ __ ] that shows great that [ __ ] comes
ability the best yeah but that was 14
days oh yeah you did all those lifetime
and her Noah Hallmark and I did three
different weeks so chances of half of
oil each week yeah so I got a point of
the head that's every three months yeah
that was that's because I had already
here adoption no you wait 90 days yeah
that first check in the moon maybe six
months yes when you look at you little
sag and see residuals and you look at
the date when it gets mailed out yeah
when you call you a coke dealer in town
listen I'm coming over Wednesday with a
big [ __ ] that below yeah this day
becomes bigger no man that's for real
though I was still sad though yeah but I
remember that whole situation there with
yeah everybody knew that Tommy was
probably not telling us what he done her
it was though who knows [ __ ] and he was
so fake to you to my face that's what
got me he he came out with never use no
matter thanks for coming tonight he came
one night with the [ __ ] scumbag and
they threatened me doesn't even matter
to see him the [ __ ] you solute of debt
yeah he threatened me they threatened me
in a weird way me I was so [ __ ] up her
drugs and so out of it at that point
that I didn't look at it as a threat so
I got hope and almost it when it got up
there in the morning would have been
with this knife but then I thought about
something I thought about what your
longevity is in any comedy club if Lee
was to walk into that Boston today even
if he was an exceptional comedian
exceptional from day one after six years
they would tell we you have to see the
shooter on the pot well does that mean
you gotta walk down Lane and get some
credits or I can only have one you won't
we could hear ya oh yeah you gotta make
a move so I had been at the copy store
it was 97 98 99 and that was 2005 maybe
mm-hmm it was time for me to go yeah I
had overstayed my welcome
ron was my fault I didn't do anything
with those seven years that's what I
feel like yes I did something with those
seven years but had to pirate I was like
I didn't use those seven years to my
advantage
I should've had more owned up to be a
great comic client I knew how to [ __ ]
improvise I was you know you say
something really important you know that
you learn how to do comedy with mitzi in
the room
so that's your personal question is is
there anything scarier than that at the
time no it's the most nervous thing ever
because but I the fact that I could get
on stage block it out and go I know my
my act I I you know I was doing some
Tribble things you know whatever I wear
I do 30 now I'm only doing 15 and I just
stuck to my guns and then I was like the
fact that I was able to block it out
with her and just focus and still be
with the crowd was an achievement and
and when you block it out you're
basically saying like man she's seen
everything don't worry about that you
know it was like trust it was like I
could trust it her after about a year or
two I looked at after two different
directions I looked at that she didn't
care whether you didn't loo or used or
old material she just wanted you to come
out to be yourself yeah I got that point
from her yeah that's what I was trying
to show I was trying to show her more of
why that's what she saw in me I wanted
her to see that he would see boy yeah
she wanted she want you even if the joke
bombs she wanted you to commit to that
joke right she would say some to you
good commitment yeah let me tell you
something quick story about you Lee
there was a show called ke Loco
ke loco was a comedy show on Telemundo
or uh and it was like um mostly
spanish-speaking comics but after a few
years they just started mixing in a lot
of different people but it's basically a
Spanish Channel but a lot of local
comics were getting a spot on it so it's
9/11 happens September 11 this is an
October this is October after 9/11 I was
already booked to do this chalo chalo Co
and we went down there and they shoot
like a bunch of episodes in a row and I
bailed on my Arab jokes cuz I was like I
don't you know [ __ ] just happen like
four weeks ago and uh so I changed them
all I'm a whole thing and I was like
I'll talk about that weird girlfriend
joke and then girls and guys and
whatever and I went out there and just
it just wasn't good and it was just bad
and I just couldn't get laughs and like
people are like what the [ __ ] is your
act what's your what are you here for
you know I mean it's a Spanish show with
black and different you know ethnicities
you know it's kind of like do your
ethnic [ __ ] this is your crowd you know
I mean and I didn't I didn't know how to
handle like that right after 9/11 a
month later I didn't know what to say
yet so anyway they do a curtain call at
the end of the show
don't call my name right I've been
standing around since 6:00 p.m. now it's
[ __ ] 9:30 10:00
you know Namine and I finally got out
there to do my six minutes and I just
I'm just [ __ ] sweating I get offstage
nobody wants to tell me exactly what
happened nobody can comprehend you know
just it was just a bomb right and uh
Bobby had left he was my ride
Bobby Lee just he's a he's gone and uh
so you were like come on I'll give you a
ride [ __ ] we could get in the [ __ ]
car and we're like you have a little car
and we're just [ __ ] flying on the 134
and I was like so happy that I was out
of there and you were like you didn't
really acknowledge it you just not only
think you saw it you know you're just
like whatever you know you gave me a pep
talk we just [ __ ] rattled our way all
the way to [ __ ] Los Feliz and you
drop me off and I was like that whole
nightmare was over but I'll never forget
that [ __ ] ride home I was also a
little scared cuz you were coked up -
you were like you finished the show the
show went great we did a little [ __ ]
this little error or driving you you're
going to the story wherever you going
and uh and you were you were on fire
Erik Erik come on Erik Erik come on it's
[ __ ] you know it was basically a pep
talk but uh I don't remember anything we
were saying I used to you know when I
wake up in the morning hey I put
something on Twitter
and people always say it's rude or
whatever but this is the things I used
to tell myself whether after once 2000
2001 came here I was a different
individual I stopped caring and that's
what made me more dangerous yep yes you
stopped caring it makes you more
dangerous inhale residual so all those
bombings I was talking myself out mmm I
was very good by the way I just
described my top two bombs right there
yeah that first set in the or that I sat
back and watched Paul Mooney all night
and that ke loco thing and then there
was there was one other though I have a
top three after that you know what I
mean you can't keep track of [ __ ]
everything but I just remember those
bombs bro yeah I mean ten thousand good
bomb right by my bobbin style but yeah a
tuxedo
you got to be probably world class top
like pantheon of of bombing with the
[ __ ] with with a with the personality
with the [ __ ] you know bombing making
an art of it Norma Donald's great at it
right
there's comics who are just so they be
they make bombing and art they take it
to the to anywhere they want then it's
like once everybody's united against you
everybody's united you can take him on
any gift you one yeah
and it's it easier when I first there
was a period at the store where I would
take long pauses I practiced taking long
pauses on purpose mmm horrible horrible
I do not suggest it that you know
Bernard does horrible horrible long
pauses to put myself in deep holes and
that's how I let it be polls right was
take long [ __ ] poses and people will
be sitting there staring self and I like
sale where you go top here Andrew Dice
class I say that's a nice thing I had
you guys quiet where I go I still move
my hand you come up to me with that
because you want to open me this weekend
go up on stage don't say a [ __ ] word
for three minutes three minutes three
million hmm do anything but say a word
don't say a word for three minutes and
you come to Vegas and JJ London's
another Cuban Jew I think isn't he
oh I haven't seen them I have to say
that I will [ __ ] remember Chen yeah I
haven't seen in a long time
what's this thing you got coming up talk
to me
these these guys these filmmakers
they've been in the business you know
and they haven't made a film in a long
time and they were really you know felt
motivated with the times we're in and
they went and asked all the Middle
Eastern comedians that they could find
how they are dealing with Trump in the
age of Trump
how are the comedian Middle Eastern
comedians handling it because you know
used to be a thing that there were even
Middle Eastern comedians now there's you
know a lot you know it was probably like
50 that are like
really good I mean that's crazy how fast
things there was none there was three
there was four I was one of the like
first four there was people who came
before us but they they never said that
they Arab had nothing to do with it he
would hide it or they just wasn't
relevant right so getting like that
so anything changed now they're going
back they interviewed everybody you know
Maz and Russell Peter and all the brown
comedians you know but but then anyway
so they just were cool guys they were
doing interviews and then they started
like getting focused on my family and
how I took kind of my flight from comedy
and married I married outside of comedy
you know I didn't marry kind of I
actually have a wife I didn't marry
comedy I guess I didn't choose because I
actually when I was I married a woman ya
know beautiful woman from Alberta
married attorney and yeah yeah lovely
very pursuit that so anyway they were
they were interested in my life and so
they shot a lot of that and with my baby
so then they end up you know using that
this picture on the poster but yeah they
they really used me as a big focus of
them of the movies tell a story of you
know how to deal with this what's going
on and all the politics you know and
like you know there was the travel ban
Muslims then there's just all the
immigrants and
all of that stuff all that [ __ ] you know
but from our perspective as Middle
Eastern people all right this is
commando okay so they're doing
screenings what is this so October 19th
yeah yeah through 21st there's gonna be
in palos verdes you know so nationwide
yes go nationwide there just happened
there just having like the little world
premiere so website they could go to
yeah so it's called travel ban like the
travel ban : make America laugh again
but travel ban make America laugh again
you could find that on Facebook or you
can just Google
the movie and you'll see the dates are
October 19th through the 25th and in New
York on December 14th through 20th in
Brooklyn
Alpine cinemas so they're having these
one-week engagements in LA and New York
so yeah it's a documentary it's just
about it's basically a documentary about
comedians how many times have you seen
that right it's follow a bunch of
comedians see what their take is how
they dealing with the times were in with
the Trump and all this [ __ ] you know
that there was no middle eastern Indian
Thomas until you two came along and then
from that country miss all the artists
and of khana Khazana my Gabriel at one
time that he went over yeah we took him
over to Armand Jordan right how big you
talk yeah I'll be YouTube was yeah they
were learning how to do stand-up they
were finishing his jokes um y-yeah from
watching YouTube over there his name is
Joe buddy they're like Jupiter and he's
like you know fluffy and everything and
they knew all of his [ __ ] he showed up
place went crazy they were finishing his
jokes he was like what the [ __ ] we met
the king the King has this over you know
like the king Oh mash and test or a man
he he delayed Russell Peters flight like
we're all in the same flight fluffy and
his group of eight or whatever they're
awesome you know and then Russell his
couple of people and it's like you know
Maz and me and I think don't know Dean
Obeidallah and uh we all get to the
airport and they detain Russell and like
did some crazy interrogation and just
turned out there was a [ __ ] [ __ ]
with them they're like the Kings like
give him the business you know I mean
just give him the business making it
make him like let everybody in and make
it seem like he's gonna miss his flight
and he can't go home and then but don't
delay the flight you know just get him
on their last minute they took him
around did some [ __ ] I don't know what
they did [ __ ] him Aaron choking all
around with them it was a pleasure
seeing you then all right Godfather
I am happy that you took the time out we
talked about you coming on the podcast a
year ago
yeah man that's not an opt-in to you and
we you know I just like I tell people if
you're not at the store and I don't see
it's so tough at him I know it's hard to
remember about with family with kids -
yeah you know you just have so please
forgive me it's nothing personal it's
just that you you down there you have
such a short window people contact you
yeah and things get in the way but I saw
your flyer no manifest give you some
love as soon as you saw that you'd call
me a no I'm here and I'm like menace I'm
just blessed to know you yeah you know
to you to ever be thought of and Leah
I'm gonna think you use some time oh
good to meet you buddy because you know
what to be thought of is sometimes you
know that's that's what you want because
sometimes you worry about what people
think but really do you know that they
would even think that you would even be
in their sphere that of people that you
would know like the fact that I could be
somewhere in your mind is like we you
know our cousins and family at them
under my brother you know my brother
Georgie K and you're right on to him
Georgie and I don't know how many times
I go to pressure number 9 I got another
talk to them I said think I'm a widow
but then I forgot them on the arm I'm
the king of the check it yeah yeah you
know call me we'll be cool like
[ __ ] I know and I wanted to
call you just reach out I saw your
poster you know East and I wanted you to
come on cuz your family I love you to
death man loved a you never judge me
when I was going through all my problems
I want to repay the favor and tell you
through your face yeah you never shunned
me you dealt with me as an addict then
you always showed me respect so I never
forgot that something is very much
before we end I'm gonna be at the improv
in West Palm Beach next weekend
October 11th through the 13th don't
quote me on the Thursday I think I might
take it out but I'll keep you guys
posted I got a meeting that day I got
some [ __ ] going on and number two I'm
over how I raised in Cleveland with my
man George Perez October 25th through
the 27th you got anything coming up
besides the movie Oh what am i doing the
Arab
American Comedy Festival in New York
City every year we do at the annual
we're in his 15th year October 11th
through 14th good enough to compete with
you [ __ ] I got my own demons to
compete Lee I love you having Kayla okay
number one since I started this podcast
people always ask me for advice
usually it's what team Tibet I don't
know think about betting on whether you
know me dog I can't but the truth is I
know who's gonna win but if you think
you know you gotta check out my bookie
remember who you're bettin on is just as
important it was who you're betting with
that's why I tell pepper people to bet
with my bookie
trust me guys they're the best bet this
season they've been in business for
years they got great reviews online and
their mobile site is easy to use I would
only recommend a service to the church
family that's been good to me you
understand me
who do you think I'm putting in the bet
wait for Conor McGregor and [ __ ]
convene this weekend my bookie why cuz
you win they [ __ ] pay that's why I'm
makhmur geing you to make your way to my
bookie they have in game live betting
over and unders on fantasy point scored
and the most rewarding player perks in
the goddamn business now my bookie is so
[ __ ] good at this land with new
betters but they want to give everybody
the best service possible especially us
from the church so if you wanted to
deposit after 7:00 p.m. Eastern at 4
o'clock California turn they'll give you
an additional $25 free play on deposits
over a yardstick that's a hundred hours
now join now and my book will match your
deposit dollar for dollar for dollar so
use promo code Church CH you are CH to
activate the offer visit my bookie
online so they do yourself a favor and
Uncle Joe your face what am i bookie
right on top of that when you create the
account put in church and they claim up
to $1,000 in free play if you weren't
the holdout for 7:00 p.m. you get the
extra 25 for every hundred by using
promo code Church it's up to you guys
but I'd wait until after dinner and take
make the extra money again my bookie you
play you win you get paid also my
favorite of all time
listen it's been six [ __ ] seven years
I've been using this stuff whether it's
the Alpha brain the shroom textbook the
shroom tech Emil
and the protein shakes I live off this
stuff now I got the little omega-3 bars
I take with me on the road that's what I
ate today is still getting the chocolate
chip cookie it's [ __ ] tremendous on
the way back from Boston so listen do me
a favor go to Ireland calm right now get
started with the shroom tech immune or
the zoomtext sport if you're working and
you're not gonna [ __ ] be sorry and
the alpha brain you having a hard time
focusing thinking is the way to go
what happened to [ __ ] adieu and all
that [ __ ] half a brain will turn you to
[ __ ] up I want to thank Boston again
for a tremendous weekend I want to thank
Foxwoods
I want to thank Aron Kader I want to
thank the flying Jew but most
importantly I want to thank you guys on
a monday woods october first we start
from zero [ __ ] go do what you got
to do have a great week uncle Joey here
kicked that [ __ ] melee